[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je crois que raymond commence à vraiment
kiffé 1 rue des bains celui-là quelle
belle entrée quelle belle entrée
franchement bravo thank you merci merci
je suis français
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être là tout va bien ouais ça va
toi
elle sait que je suis là des fonds
boucle moi je défends tout le monde à
vous avez vu ce soir je vous aime
beaucoup serré un baril merci ça fait
vraiment plaisir parce que voilà je me
fais rire en tout cas voilà elle tente
des choses moi j'aime bien les gens les
gens qui ne font rien on sait qu'on les
critique ra jamais voilà donc elle au
moins elle essaie de faire détruite mais
après on aime ou on aime pas l effet
alors rugby tu vend toujours le moins
vendu de bouteilles d'eau tombent à
aujourd'hui bah j'en ai
près du coup j'ai décidé de déléguer un
petit peu j'ai des employés c'est vrai
c'est devenu une notion de bien et si
amazon
[Rires]
j'ai créé de l'emploi non mais sérieux
comme moi tu viens de bouteilles par
jour environ
ac c'est privé je suis pas répondre à
cette question et en vend plus qu'une
poussée privé une veille à temps avant
le drame et sans et parce que la non la
bouteille à 1500 jetons à paris d'une
une peut-être peut-être hui peut-être
nous mais là à 39 euros sa part comme
des petits pains
ça pleure comme des petites tartines ou
alors je mens toujours tes culottes oui
franc et s'en vanterait tu l'aimés
qu'une fois en fait tu te lèves ans
après ce que tu me dis mais quelques
jeux les portes quelques heures et
ensuite elle apporte moines dans trois
quatre heures c'est après le bain oui
oui d'accord il fait pareil avec ses
couches
[Rires]
et
sa part pas d'eau alors on voulait
revenir là dessus parce que y'en a pas
la peine moins de temps c'est vrai qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens qui ont été choquées
par la vente de ton ton nous nos du bain
avant deux de tes culottes dans un
instant notre avocat que ce soit les
anneaux nous dira qu'en fait c'est
illégal ce que tu fais tu gagnes tu vas
nous dire pourquoi tu vas nous dira si
elle en prison sur ina peut-être oui bah
tu n'as pas donner ton avis non j'ai
pardonné dans la vie quoi ouais et
pourtant je vous dire qu'ils ingèrent
regarder ça m'a pas du tout choquée
voilà et je veux dire pourquoi ça m'a
pas choqué parce que pour moi larnack
c'est quand on vend quelque chose par
exemple si elle avait dit je vends lônes
mon bain et avec cette eau là vous allez
être guéri de maladie vous et les deux
stars vous allez être riche c'était la
bac de ré vous vous souvenez de de jeu
peu comment il s'appelait rac doré de
dan et gilbert lisait si vous achetez
mad max mais si elle devine une vielle
dame en ciel des justes acheter l'eau de
mon bain à des fans et tout ça vous fera
rien mais juste d'acheter l'eau tombe un
pardon s'il ya des gens je vais pas dire
des contes comme c'est des gens qui ont
envie d'acheter notre son bain parce
qu'elles sont pas qu'il le fasse quel
est le problème le problème des bleus en
a vendu une belge de ses cheveux il a
pas dit vous devez reste et vous aurez
une mèche justin bridou avant du jeu
aussi sont
rien d'illégal je voudrais ça va vous
faire acheter un truc faut savoir que
madonna sont en 1987 elle est bien jeter
sa couleur sur leurs actionnaires ça a
choqué parce que vous avez donc
je vais vous avouer que ces paramètres
il est aujourd'hui niveau du banc du
bandit naturellement je ne porte pas de
culotte
ça sent bon ben ça c'est une info médias
ah oui donc la pac pilote vous êtes
recul est énorme et ça soit d'accord nos
escales d'illégal dans le mais vous ne
savez frappe un nom vous savez choc
parce que j'étais pas là hier ça vous
choque alors c'est vraiment parce qu'on
a des points communs mathieu j'ai pensé
la même chose ce match convient ou non
mais c'est pas tous crocs krill pascal
ne promets pas que ça va faire du bien
ça va guérir quoi que ce soit donc voila
moi ce qui me choque c'est mais c'est
même pas vous mademoiselle c c'est un
ensemble de choses c'est que
malheureusement vous avez énormément de
followers suisses 488 quelque chose
comme ça vous avez vous de vous devenez
un symbole de réussite pour des jeunes
filles très jeunes et c'est ça qui me
choque pas tant mieux bien à ben
non enfin moi j'aime
[Musique]
je pense qu'on les a bien évidemment
mais c'est justement ce n'est pas contre
vous c'est contre un système manger je
n'aimerais pas que les les jeunes filles
que ce modèle avis avant
qui n'avance pas recule beaucoup mais on
est notre génération tu vends des
paninis est-ce que départ ma vie en
général leur fille
du beurre
je m'amuse avec des cadets 1 contre et
mademoiselle vie mais il s'est allongé
il est bon s'il est en même temps il est
où le problème on s'émerveille à autun
pr gilles moi ce qui me choque pas voir
ma fille c'est que une artiste comme
vous une rappeuse comme vous elle se
dévoue corps vendant pas non non tu vas
partir c'est à dire je suis choqué par l
elle me choque en faisant ça pour que
j'ai perdu l'estiment que j'avais bel
c'est ça mais parce qu' elle n'a pas à
faire sa culotte de rumigny canon j'ai
passé la culotte n'ont pas d'arguments
et non parce que c'est pas digne d'elle
mais est ce un argument il est venu et
c'est un argument la dignité
là il est pas toujours dignes à chérir
chaque émission vous avez même gilles
verdez savoir un truc gilbert gilles
c'est gilbert
gelber days écoutez moi bien on soit
faut savoir que je suis pas
politiquement correct que dans le rap
mois de base de bashung gangsters
mais
illégal en fait donc en soi après bon
voilà je m'amuse je tape dans mon bain
je m'amuse dans le bain et je me suis
dit pourquoi pas faire de cette eau et
ont pu le sachet et quoi manger il une
rebelle et la
robine